welcome to this video playing off one
yeah this is a great master and a
handoff man i think the handoff one Gran
maestro isn't Spanish a really nice
language sounds much better than course
master German go on maestro yeah ok
let's see we have a um we have a bogo
with 92 this is a sideline that I
sometimes play a little bit irritated he
that he just canceled mmhmm yeah maybe
93 yes this could be happening but I
still think I can I can castle first ok
so it seems that he's not really worried
much about the porn here hmm I mean 94
and I win this porn he might get some
compensation but I don't really see this
as a so great maybe i'm wrong but what
exactly is your comp here it's a big
central pawn it's not some unimportant
flank porn ok don't you try to keep the
CSS is the only possibility that that
makes some sense out of this out of this
pawn seg ok needed some water him um I'm
a little bit I'm underdeveloped
but aunty six might be a weakness hmm ok
I'm going to take him yeah c5 hangs
think I should cover that if he goes
Bishop f4 ok with the aid and yeah
should be six here or rugby aid look the
one is coming you know what I should do
I should take him and play but should be
six quickly get this counter play going
that's it that's probably probably good
before he gets in rook t1 and and this
pressure on d6 white has some some some
compensation here anyway yeah Bishop c4
yeah him he might exchange give up the
exchange to take on b7 at the end
yeah still still I should take it I
guess okay it's not giving up the
exchange um so d5 now to to cover c4
didn't see that one coming
unfortunately where I say porn is rather
strong hmm
poo
hmm now day seven porn is a problem
problem really how do i get to that pawn
I really don't know some way maybe 9 to
e six by two is six and I can be maybe
this is an idea attacking the bishop on
default guy plate plate very quickly so
cannot attack this I cannot play d4 yeah
it's not good rook e8 probably not a
good as well and 28 and d4 maybe
something like that yeah at the rook
here time warning I can just he had a
she could have taken but okay that's
probably there are multiple solutions
now it's just this position is too
strong simply cannot defend this
unfortunately
all right i can just takes you five and
on f7
yeah I'd simply overlooked loop takes
7-10 b6 could have just taken g5 and I
resign it doesn't matter very much
because I'm I'm lost anyway but Queen a8
now okay black resigns yeah I just
forgot about you get seven if I don't do
that think I should be should be okay I
don't think you should have more than
compensation here it probably should
lead to something we're all pawns are
traded yeah I mean I of course i saw i
saw a 97 here but i thought i can just
take I didn't see ruka it's heaven and
then be six some something like that is
really no problem i always have this
square yeah that's totally okay but here
it's really really already a problem i
have a defense actually what he did
isn't good at all i have Rooke a form
which i forgot about ah ok and he I'm
upon up for good compensation or four
white but but still he doesn't have the
a7 porn yeah that was bad I wasn't no
bit too too shocked by this know he is
winning yeah the worst thing is that
white is so overwhelming he couldn't
even play some some really bad news like
not taking on g5 but it's it's still a
total win so it doesn't really matter so
much yeah so this boss was perfectly
fine i just have to i just have to be a
alert this one moment and and just play
rugae for instead of Quincy six and then
this all to play for I mean yeah that he
has compensation but it's never enough
never more than then enough here should
be okay for black all the time okay
thanks for watching